and uh and by the way it was built by
audience we asked them when we switched
over from tv to online
can you guys uh help us build this and
our audience gave us 425 000
to
uh
[Music]
this is what he does
okay okay okay right he basically
basically
he's funny because he makes money right
he watched right
by trying to
[Music]
livestream's getting divided
right it's like there's lower numbers
okay hey uh do you never should try to
own your own show or your own panel i
know right like i know like this guy's
writing like
this [ __ ] this book
i'm trying to read
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you know
[Music]
i know i
know school
so here's what happened alex jones
invaded our segment like this at the rnc
so now all these right-wing guys all
these
guys they get
numbers young church because we got like
100 million views on youtube every month
came on our show and it's [ __ ] okay
it's right like if i don't like when i
say [ __ ] by assigned for like
like you know it's real talk it's like
run sensor
okay so okay
what's this guy's real name steven
crowder i'm saying that's exactly what
he wanted
that's why the shows came out
come on
i know i can do it all the time
[Music]
but by the way guys you shouldn't
download like that
it's cute right i know it's okay
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry thanks so much appreciate no
problem everything you do all right big
fan even if your audience is dwindling
okay you should subscribe right
otherwise that's [ __ ] okay
you don't subscribe you're gonna be one
of those homophobic right wingers
who rises my dick right